foreign
[Music]
hi my name is caroline labresco and i am
the founding director of a program
called sundance catalyst
thank you caroline i'm michael dweck the
uh one of the directors producers and
cinematographers of the truffle hunters
and i'm gregory kershaw the other
director producer and cinematographer of
the truffle hunters
so tell me what what drew you to this
place it's the town is
is called piedmont right or p how do you
pronounce it
yeah pimon is the region and that's the
region the
yeah and there's sort of there's a
center of it of the truffle trade it's
called out the
the town is called alba and that's sort
of this the commercial center of the
truffle trade but really most of our
filming was done
deep in the in the secret forests around
around that area
this world it felt like moving through
it just it felt like
a fairy tale and there were there was
just there was a feeling there was
something sort of
magical in the air it didn't it it was a
place that it held on to
it's its identity there was a continuity
with the local tradition and
it it didn't feel like it had been taken
over by
global technology and global culture
and all that and that alone was just so
fascinating but then we had heard about
these these truffle hunters and we had
heard
these you know whisperings of these
these old men who went into the woods
the into their secret truffle forest in
the middle of the night
with their dogs to find these the
white truffle which sometimes sells for
as much as gold
i mean it's it's it's it's a mushroom
it's a fungus that sometimes sells for
as much as gold and so you know
what we were just there before we
started thinking about this as a film
project we had asked around and said you
know can we meet some of these guys and
everybody said no no no no you can't
meet these guys no one even knows who
they are i mean
so there was a secret and we're like
okay well
we have to go back and explore this and
we just we started
we went back kind of just to see what we
could find and
i think immediately we looked at each
other and said this is this is our next
project and you know three years later
we had a film but it was
it that was the beginning of a very long
process because everything in this world
is a secret talk to me about how did you
penetrate
this world and how did you gain the
trust
of these amazing 85 to 95 year old
men who carried this ancient tradition
and this secret world with them
well we spent we spent a lot of time
with them um
you know we made the film over three
years and over that time we entered
deeply into their lives of the people we
were filming
initially we had you know there was the
layer of
tourist truffle hunters you know the
guys that kind of wore uniforms and
took tourists into the woods and buried
a truffle before they got there and a
dog
wow dug it up and then they have dinner
there's that there's that group which is
most of most of the world thinks maybe
this is that region that they found a
truffle but then there's this
other group of people that don't want to
be discovered
that are um are farmers during the day
and truffle hunters at night and
you know so you know we spent we ended
up uh
it took us maybe six months to maybe
meet the first real truffle hunter and
you know over a lot of wine and espresso
uh you know
we attempted to to bring the most
interesting aspects of our lives
uh you know what they wanted to share
with us into the story
um and do it through you know like a you
know carefully
considered cinematic approach how did
you prove to them that you were
trustworthy
i think a lot of it was that we you know
the first time we were there
you know we we we really we didn't we
didn't have a camera with us and we were
just meeting people and we
said okay we're gonna we're gonna come
back we we we mike michael lives in new
york city i live
i live in stockholm sweden and we said
you know we're going to come back in
two weeks and they said yeah sure yes
sure and then we came back in two weeks
and we and we stayed for you know we
stayed for a month we kept
doing that over and over so i think they
i think that was you know they
they realized that we weren't going away
but it was best they would leave
yeah they understand what's happening in
the world around them and i think they
realize that they're disappearing from
the world
not just truffles i mean not just
truffles it's everything that surrounds
it our characters are 85 to 90 year old
characters
and these are people that you know at
night they're walking you know 15 20
kilometers a night
in the dark on cliffs in the mud in the
cold without trying to
keep up with them and uh like greg was
saying they were just that very healthy
and their their
mural and and happy and joyful mirthful
lives that they had
uh and because i think they're very
close to nature
close to their animals and they live
very very simple lives it is bizarre
how you know these truffles that they
they they
come out of the earth in this very
simple magical way and end up on the
place of people
in you know hong kong dubai new york
city paris and
for you know thousands and thousands of
dollars so there was there was
i guess there was an absurdity to that
too that that was important to us
telling the story to capture this
difference between you know different
between classes and how they how they
you know had this bizarre
interaction yes there's a black market
yes that happens at three o'clock in the
morning
in this little town that nobody ever
nobody
well nobody knows about except for the
truffle hunters and the truffle dealers
and the first night the first year we
went there it had been a drought
it hadn't rained close to six months uh
and we you know
and we asked we went to the town during
the day and we asked the
storekeeper is there a like 60 or 70
bunch of 80 year old guys in front of
your store training truffle three in the
morning he says
no i would know i have literally my
whole life there's nothing happens out
my window i'd hear about it of course
this truffle hunter said go there at
three in the morning and there it was
three in the morning it was alive with
these men and trench coats it was
raining with these hats on
and this car pulls up and it opens the
back and it's the whole
town reeks of truffles and all these
truffle dealers ran to the car and was
trying to make a deal
to try to buy these truffles because
they were doing none around and then
they just scatter
they scatter like nothing ever existed
down these alleyways and all the deals
are made
in the shadow of a church that's how
secretive this
this whole little world is it's uh it's
fascinating it all starts with the fact
that
the white truffle can't be cultivated so
no one
no one knows why a white truffle really
grows where it grows
and how it grows everybody kind of has
their their own theory you talk to
somebody and they think it's when
lightning strikes a tree that a truffle
will come out of it some people think
it's
dependent on the faces of the moon they
you know
everybody has their own their own little
theory some people there's even water
diviners that they use to find truffles
and they're actually quite
quite successful with finding them but i
guess the
the one you know really the one
dependable thing is
is these the people who do it the
truffle hunters that we film with first
they have dogs that have the ability to
they have a great sophisticated sense of
smell
and then they train them over three
years so they become they become up they
become obsessed with finding truffles
that's what they live for once
once they kind of once they get the
scent and um
but they also have this this knowledge
it's a knowledge that's passed on it's
guarded
and sometimes it's passed through the
generations but then like some of the
truffle hunters that we would
film with they would they keep these
detailed records
of every time they find a truffle they
write exactly where they found it
they write what the where the moon was
what phase of the moon it was when they
found it they
wrote they write the last time it rained
the time of year so they had these
detailed maps that have this tremendous
amount of information
thinking that if they know if they
understand
what conditions brought about a truffle
they understand the tree that gave that
truffle because it
the truffles they only grow on
particular trees in the region usually
oak trees and if a truffle produces
if a tree produces a truffle one year it
will likely produce one the next year if
the conditions are the same but that
that knowledge is is
guarded so secretly and
no truffle hunter will ever share that
with with any other
any other truffle hunter or even us we
got we
you know we were basically blindfolded
when we were brought into these spots
so you have these incredible characters
you've gained the trust of the town at
this point
let's talk about how you chose to tell
this story
it started with you know this this
feeling of the place
this this you know this idea that this
world to us
it felt like a fairy tale and that was
really before we even
before we even started filming we just
we knew we didn't know what the stories
were we didn't go into this world with a
story
we just we knew there was a feeling that
we wanted to capture
and and we we started sort of
experimenting early on with just
different ways of capturing it but it
came
it came it became quite clear to us
pretty early on that we wanted this
world we wanted the audience to feel
what we felt while we were
in this world we wanted to bring the
audience into this
fairy tale experience that that that we
were living while we were there and
that's what led us to this idea of these
these locked house frames we wanted each
frame to feel like
a page in the story that we were
bringing the audience through
and we we we wanted to think about you
know
we wanted to think about how we could
use the documentary form and use the
verite documentary form but use it in a
different way because i think you know
there's
there's generally when you're when
you're making when you're following real
life
you're you're handheld with a camera
following people around
and we we thought well what if we do
something different what if we just
set the camera up and just observe
and it took us a long time to figure out
how to do that
because it's it's it's very tricky
because the world doesn't want to fit in
a frame and that's why we shot the film
we shot the film over three years
because
so you know we would usually we would
shoot one shot a day
at at most and sometimes we would shoot
nothing but
you know to get that one shot it was
like waiting for all these
different aspects of the filmmaking
process to come
together yeah it was like waiting for
the right moment
waiting for the technical things to be
right like it's the sun where we want it
it's the is the light does the light
look
nice through that window that we're
filming and then also finding like
finding frames that that you know not
we're just
we weren't really looking for the most
beautiful frame but we were looking for
the frame that helped
the audience feel what we were feeling
like what what is the frame that is
going to
bring the audience into that space let
them feel the warmth of the fire let
them feel the cold stone
floor you know all those things you know
and they're little but
when you're watching the film hopefully
you have a chance to to study these
images and and and through doing that
you're brought into them and you're
brought into the
subjective space of of the characters
worlds
and then there's the dogs we had the
idea to put a camera on a dog's head
you know we thought that you know the
the uh
through the canine perspective
perspective uh we wanted the audience to
see how the dog sees
um and you know come to understand
you know how they react in the forest
their relationship with the truffle
hunter
um you know and experience this unique
relationship
that they share uh with their companion
um so you know in contrast to the
main footage that greg was just talking
about uh this footage you know was
continuously in motion
and it was driven by this you know this
frenetic action of the dog
in pursuit of the prize and we looked
through the camera
at the footage and we felt like we were
the dog yeah and we felt the energy
that the dog had uh and it was and it
was great and then we also mounted
microphones little tiny microphones like
the size of a piece of rice
and we mounted those in the dog's paws
on the dog ears and the dog's nose
you know little tiny ones and also the
same with the truffle hunter the scene
with the the the clip carter the clip
yes
yes the clip is the tuna really oh
truffle hunter and
and carlos not carlo carlos uh who's a
young
a younger truffle hunter okay and uh who
wants
aurelio secrets and you know he's of
course by coincidence
he's met orillio in the woods when he's
truffle hunting
and thinks oh i bumped into you maybe we
can become friends and it really of
course is not
that stupid so he's so he knows he knows
that uh he's not going to give anything
up and this arrangement this is
something they both spoke about
carlos would ask us i know your friends
of orillio
can you please ask him if he would share
secrets with us
and uh and i said look this up to him
and then really i would say you know we
hear about this guy carlos he
he met me in the woods twice and he's
trying to steal my secrets and follow me
and walk my paths and
so one day they got together
at this lunch table and uh
and he decided to go for it because you
know he thought
aurelio was talking to people in the
town it's a very very small town where
he lives in
leo so he's saying well maybe i saw your
you know in that conversation you're old
and you have the secrets and uh
and and i want them and he's saying to
him you have to do what i did i was six
years old when i started
and i've been doing this 80 years and uh
and you're going to pay your dues i'm
not going to tell you anything and
that's why at the end of the scene he
says well
if you you had children you tell him he
said never
and that's how he and that's that's how
he feels you know i just want to end by
talking about
um kind of coming back out to the
real you know the real world out of the
fairy tale of the
of the film film and into the real world
and
kind of the danger of losing this this
culture
you know i guess we we approach a
project almost like cultural
anthropologists
um we um uh
we're concerned obviously about
communities disappearing
um we have an obsession with looking for
these uh you know trying to
search for worlds that have held on to
these deep-rooted traditions
and have retained their identities um
you know in this world where
you know globalization and technology
really
has stripped away a lot of the souls of
many many communities when you're
looking for
these worlds as we are where you're
looking for places that have you know
that have held on to
to their identity that that haven't been
consumed by globalism you realize how
how rare they are i mean it's just
when you trout you know when you travel
around the world it's becoming
everything is becoming so much the same
so quickly
and technology is transforming the way
people
all around the world live in and and and
completely removing them from
from the cultures that they've grown
from
and and there's tremendous good that
it's come from technology and there's a
lot that we
want to move away from in the past but
there's i think there's a lot of
value also in in looking back to the
past because there's a lot of knowledge
and wisdom that
that's there too that's that's also
being lost
and when you explore a world that that
is still held on to that you you get to
pull those little pieces
of of knowledge and wisdom and you get
to you know you get to
take them and we hope we you know we
tried to weave those
we tried to weave that into the story
and it's you know
it was it was very it was simple
knowledge it was simple wisdom
but we saw the people that we were
following we saw how rich their lives
were we saw
how fulfilled they were as human beings
how just simply healthy they were
and there were simple things that they
they held onto but they really
they they they made their lives
meaningful
thank you so much for this conversation
i could go on and on thank you
so much thank you caroline thank you so
much
it's a movie that i love from the bottom
of my heart it is such a joy to watch
to know these characters in this world
and enter into
frankly a delicious feast for the eyes
ears
and one can only imagine for the palette
okay we hope you taste the truffle when
you
when you when you watch it we hope you
can taste the truffle i think you can